[Music]
perhaps the most common question that I
get is how can I lose fat it could be
anywhere on your body and it could be
that you haven't started and you have
trouble even catalyzing fat loss and I
say fat loss instead of weight loss
because you want to watch body
composition not just the scale or it
could be that you've plateaued so you've
lost a little bit of weight and now
you're stuck and you can't drop there
are two changes or things that I
recommend focusing on the first is
breakfast if you nail breakfast even if
you don't change any of your other meals
any other behaviors that is often enough
to lose 10 to 20 pounds per month fat
and I've seen this thousands of times
now the dream breakfast I would say is
going to check two boxes number one
you're gonna have breakfast within 30
minutes of waking up so you can think of
it as 30 within 30 30 grams of protein
within 30 minutes waking up and the meal
that I would suggest is something like
two or three eggs then you have lentils
or black beans and then some type of
green vegetable like spinach right you
don't have to do that you could just
have black beans or something like that
Amy's organic a medium Chile this one I
use this morning for instance right out
of the can plus some eggs and you get
two things you get protein which has a
high thermic effect of food and will
inhibit your appetite somewhat for the
rest of the day so you might consume say
anywhere from 20 to 30% fewer calories
than otherwise you're also consuming a
lot of fiber which is going to leave you
feeling full satiated for many hours
afterwards this is a really really key
component
alright so breakfast that's it simple
early and also checking the protein and
fiber boxes second piece is if you drink
coffee tea anything like that
instead of using milk and trust me I
don't care if it's almond milk or some
other type of fancy milk that you think
isn't real milk no almost all of those
are going to spike insulin and glucose
levels use a tablespoon or two of full
fat cream instead and then if you want a
little bit of flavor add some cinnamon
to that
and with that change alone even if you
don't handle the breakfast piece I've
seen people lose yet again 1015 pounds
in a given month so those are two very
simple things you can do and overarching
that remember fat loss in 99% diet you
can't out work your mouth so focus on
the food
you